[Music]
brought to you by me on these guys no
more riding up the bum no more soggy
underwear time to get you some of me on
these three times softer than cotton new
designs each month shipped right to your
door guys you're getting a 20% off free
shipping and our 100% satisfaction
guarantee get the best softest dankest
underwear there is family
I'm wearing this it's gonna be green
screen I'll probably go to meet a nice
calm / annejulien I'm sitting on my
front wedgie on me are you okay yeah I
get 20% off and free shipping and it's
gonna change your underwear life guys
full and look like you're naked but
you're not it's even cooler than that
also guys brought to you by wink Merlot
Chardonnay rose a cabernet sauvignon
pinot noir me Pinot Grigio me guys
that's confusing okay let wink do the
hard work for you when it comes to wine
wink is a service you hear me like I'm
like wheezing no it's fine I'm just like
exerted myself from the intro yeah I'm
okay
guys if you don't know anything about
wine the difference it makes when you
have wink on your side is they they do
all the hard work for you they they get
your palate profile you take a little
quiz and then they send you wine that's
tailored to your specific taste I like
preference and its really awesome guys
they send curated wines directly to your
front door every month our new delicious
wines and their great
there's no membership fees you can skip
any month and cancel anytime mm-hmm
check it out by going to try wink that's
t ry winc comm slash annejulien for $20
off i just got kicked to get wine
delivered to you i told you that one of
the conditions of having the dogs in the
room when we podcast is you can't allow
him to cry either then so okay you only
cried once and kicked me in a circle
maybe put him somewhere
peach no that's your daughter okay if
you put Kermit up top he'll stay up
there okay guys you want to go seven
yeah little bit we will be resuming soon
I back in that well what are we doing
today it's old favorite things
except we ate Oprah we Jenna and we
always wanted to make a favorites video
I just never thought I was like cool
enough to do that well I feel like when
people do them it's like beauty
community sort of and they have like new
products every months we want to know
like what you like that month but I mean
we're just normal people just no more
less you could probably make like one
favorites thing but I couldn't make you
a favorites video every month my
favorites um uh Pheebs I just don't have
that many things but I think this could
be a cool series to have because I do
have things that I like and you see in
vlogs and whatnot but to highlight them
specifically is cool because cool things
and things that are worth your money
they're worth talking about and they're
worth your money too I think fish eh so
keep in mind the things that's most
worth your money is winking me undies
okay but beneath that we are going to be
showing you some of our favorite things
that we use in our life whether it's
everyday life or work or whatever for
pleasure I have on this table amassed a
group of items namely this fanny pack
what is holding a bunch of smaller items
that we're going to show you I want
Jenna to start though so okay well my
first thing is no surprise
and they actually on my body okay my
first favorite thing is black leggings
straight black high-waisted beautiful
amazing well these ones are from
Lululemon and I understand that they're
like $90 and some people don't like that
but as the legging connoisseur let me
tell you I used to buy mini $10 pairs of
leggings and then I will always walk
around with a hole in my butt and I was
like it's just part of my pants I can't
get to the store right the second stop
making fun of me
but I finally why
listening this is a riveting story I
finally like invested in one pair of
lulu lugging Lululemon leggings like I
don't know five years ago and I still
have them like I'd say how quality you
get what you pay for
yeah like three or four pairs of just
the plain black ones that have lasted me
you know people whine about the pilling
or stuff that sometimes happens with the
different materials but like I really
haven't experienced a lot of that and
they're like don't put them in the dryer
and I'm like oh do they want I put all
of them in the dryer yeah and they're
all fine and I don't give a [ __ ] yeah
you dry and wash them and dry them and
wash them the [ __ ] out of them and they
don't break ever together they have very
specific wash and dry instructions and
you ignore all of them and they still
last yeah I just don't care yeah but I
would say like money-wise like I went
through enough pairs of like cheap ones
that would probably equal one solid pair
of like $90 leggings from Lululemon and
it would have lasted me the same amount
of time cuz I Oh like I used to go to
this place next to my grocery store in
Boston and buy leggings and they were
literally like ten dollars and then I
like there's so many pictures of me like
wearing them and such and they just
would there be a hole in the butt you
know I was like it's just there's a hole
in my butt I'm very sorry about it but
I'm 30 now and I can't just do that
there should only be one hole in your
butt cuz now it's like excuse me lady
Wow
lady you can't just walk around like
that and I'm like I'm so sorry I'm an
adult you know what I mean but to me for
like my personal preferences and a
legging which is I like them to be long
cuz I wear my socks under here and then
I wear them like down on my feet so I've
kind of short legs you know but I like
that it feels really God and I like when
it goes up to here feels Rolly guard you
know others think that they're really
clod good yeah no material that I have a
couple different ones in a different
material but I I like just the regular
ones but I don't really [ __ ] with the
crop ones or like the you just like the
straight up just straight black ones
they make your butt look good well like
how much do I wear these every day every
day I mean that's I'm getting my money's
worth
yeah you know in a mirror and I would
dress them up and
out two things so yeah they're also
they're not only my cash pants but they
my dress pins cash pants okay on the
topic of clothing my my first one is
nutrition it's not clothing yes but I
would take a bath in it and it's also
one of my favorite things I didn't write
on the list but I love you anywhere from
like three to seven full containers of
this in the house at at any given time
its nutritional yeast or nooch or the
the gold lifeblood of vegans I don't
know this is something that makes
anything taste
cheesier better just wonderful you can
put it literally on anything you're
cooking pasta
yep that's literally all we cook no like
sauces yeah even just like you can even
throw it on like a salad dressing or
whatever like yeah anything you're
making this will make it so much better
there will be a time when we're like
we're making a pizza sauce or like a
lentil Bolognese or something and you
want it to just be a little cheesy or
thicker you throw some new chin there
and it looks like morose weird it looks
like fish food it's got like flakes a
peach go away go so it's a popcorn this
is a popcorn that we make yeah you can
so basically you can use this for spices
so you get like it acts as like a cheesy
sort of binder right um and it's it's
amazing it's like I don't even know it's
yeah this is just if you're if you're in
need of some vegan cheese substitutes or
a cream whatever substitutes this is
what you want not cream well it makes
things creamy you can cream things yet
but it's not like a but but so we make a
popcorn where you you like do the oil in
your pot and then you put your your
popcorn kernels in there and then you
can use the vegan butter if you feeling
a little naughty but we do a mix of that
garlic powder onion powder and salt and
you put that on popcorn it makes this
like delicious [ __ ] cheesy popcorn
amazing yes and it has B vitamins in it
okay go buy this you will not be
disappointed it's amazing well yeah if
you're into it you don't have to buy
actually I'm selling this one
ten dollars no no yeah he's definitely
stable in the kitchen okay your turn
newt newt okay I'm pretty sure that I've
shown this many a time but one of my
favorite things is this amazing
rosewater facial spray with aloe herbs
minerals and a word that I can't
pronounce
but this one is actually like almost
empty but so I originally got this
because I was looking for sort of like a
toner and rosewater makes really nice
toner but this one was cheap like this
is maybe ten dollars but this is a big
size and that was just at my beauty
supply store like you could probably get
it for cheaper than that somewhere else
but this lasts so long I love it when
it's super hot and you're just like out
in the world and you're like God [ __ ]
hot and you just pull this out and spray
your face with it first of all it feels
amazing it's moisturizing hydrating love
it but I'm also a cheap [ __ ] and I use
this as my setting spray when I'm doing
my makeup because it's like the one
thing it has going for it is that it
smells good when you spray it everywhere
oh that one was too but this this was
the like honey we in van nuys that was a
crackhead moment this is do that in
public you're gonna get some weird looks
but hey I swear though like there's some
days when it's like really hot and I
wash my face then I put spray this on a
little bit do like a light moisturizer
and this like sort of keeps my skin
moisturize enough for the day you know
what I mean yeah but this is so much
cheaper than a makeup setting spray
where they sell you a thing that's this
big I don't know like this yeah I guess
I guess it probably is a more economical
yeah but it probably isn't like as good
but I don't know I'm not super into like
the setting spray have something other
than is there a chemical in it that
makes makeup stay I don't know about
chemical but I have no idea what they're
made of I know that some people like
certain ones other than other ones but
I've tried like the Urban Decay one and
the NYX one herbal tea cake herbal the
case re doing in my bed and I felt like
this did the same thing if anything just
made my skin more hydrated then a turn
setting spray but I am NOT a beauty
expert you'll have to ask someone that
knows what they're [ __ ] talking about
but I used this more I would say for
like I like throwing in my bag and going
around and spraying it when it's hot
it's like you know when you're a kid and
you had one of those fans with a water
bottle in it and you would spray it on
yourself it's like that for adults but
like with some stuff that'll make you
skin nice
all right amazing I love it love it and
I set my makeup I already know how much
you use that thing so I go through a lot
of she's not lying it's like one of your
favorite things it's also on my favorite
things to ask people if they'd like to
get sprayed and then spray them would
you like a spray no I'm wearing glasses
do not app I feel better already
tbh I feel amazing for a second with my
hydro that's probably your favorite
thing in the whole world
that thing is attached to your body
hydro flasks are very popular you
probably know what it is this is the
growler version they have different
names for different sizes I initially
bought my one of my best friends the
growler for I think Christmas or his
birthday or something and cuz he is he's
a big dude and he hydrates a ton and he
would appreciate the fact that it stays
cold in this you know vacuum insulated
whatever but is this massive I don't
know how many liters or whatever it's
like let's see 64 ounces 1.9 liters
that's a [ __ ] lot and for me I always
have the smaller one but I found myself
refilling it like 64 ounces isn't that
like if you drank one of those a day
that's like what they say you should
like eight eight cups or something
eight eight ounce glasses of water a day
yeah I guess it's like a full day but
you go through like three of those a day
I go through a two of them a day but
having a refill at once in the middle of
day instead of like three times
throughout the day is amazing they have
the top you need to stop crying because
we're podcasting you needed like
literally stop crying
also shouts out really quickly to our
awesome friends at pub G for giving us
these awesome partner hoodies with our
names on them yeah
chuckling okay anyway so it stays cold
often times I will forget to take this
home from jiu-jitsu and I will get it
the next day and it is still cold the
water is still cold in it and then
that's how long it stays cold it's
incredible and it doesn't stick out at
all especially you get a color like this
but you have that special mouthpiece on
that makes that right yeah see if you
pop it up his is like squishy at the
time so it's really nice like the ones
where you just open them and drink out
of I hate that are you so yeah you get
the sippy top and it has it has a little
distraught thing yeah that's amazing I
love this thing so stay hydrated with
your hydrophobic next to you at all
hours of the day yeah that's always with
Julian it's great all right my next
favorite thing is ginger candies this is
probably one of your favorite things too
right
gin gins where's the yellow bag okay so
not for you I didn't know what these
were Julian introduced me to these but
something that I do know about myself is
that ginger is like really magical to me
like I don't know if you know that
before you met me like what and you knew
that like it would help actually no yeah
I didn't know that ginger had that
effect on me and tell him at you so I
get like really for always like my whole
life like seafood has made me really
sick like if it's just in or around
anything like I get physically nauseous
and I have thrown up from trying it when
I was the kid and my dad was like you
like it I'm like that no I really don't
think I'm gonna like it I think I'm
gonna throw up and it makes me throw up
not like allergic like I don't get hives
but it makes me physically [ __ ] so
yeah and you know sometimes just like
flying or like motion sickness or stuff
like that I'm like I always was like I
don't want to take Dramamine like I
don't want to feel weird or whatever and
Julian told me I think it was because I
had accidentally ingested fish we were
in Australia years was that the first
time and I yeah and you had wee
basically had lot laksa locks that's
what it was is it wait is it luck sir I
don't know Rome says it with a weird
accent and then LTS ka laksa laksa yes
Elliot la que si Lok whatever it's a
sorry it's like a it's art is it
vietname no it's taught something
Chinese Thai it's popular in Australia
Rome showed us what it was she we order
Jenna the veggie option right it turns
out the broth had had fish in it and
Morgan is not but it just must have been
cooked in new with something with fish
and it just means yes and so Jenna was
like ill like she was like borderline
vomiting not she hasn't like wasn't
vomiting but she was like really
nauseous all of a sudden it kind of hit
her all at once so I ran down to the
local pharmacy and she was like you know
get and get whatever you can and I found
these ginger tablets which normally I
would say you have to really dig for
those at pharmacies like CVS or wherever
you are on they're not they're not the
front of the aisle but at the front of
how is the Dramamine or the anti-nausea
medication over-the-counter stuff but
I've always been a fan of ginger because
growing up I've always had the worst
stomach and ginger has been one of the
things that consistently made my nausea
go down my stomach pain go down so I I
got her the medicine but I was like I'm
gonna try these ginger tablets cuz I
think she probably if I can get her to
take them which is gonna be a hard task
they're gonna work yeah cuz I was like
um I don't know if you heard me but like
I'm gonna [ __ ] throw up and Ginger's
not gonna help it yeah throw that up too
but so I took it and my nausea just
disappeared
and again those tab like ginger tablets
are kind of hard to find in the u.s. I
have been able to find them you can
finally ginger gum and you can find
ginger candies I have been able to find
any real ginger tablets but either way
the ginger in the candy and the gum does
sort of do the same thing for me as long
as it's made with pure ginger yeah and
then like after that like I would keep a
bunch of ginger because we found some in
Japan too of like ginger candies those
are really good and I never travel
without them yeah so I would leave them
in my backpack to travel with and then I
would find myself being like oh the
candy come won't eat that ball but I
want to save it till sometime I'm like I
don't feel that good we were traveling
or something you know I should say that
I'm like I don't know company so we
found this at Whole Foods this is this
whole like brand and line is Jin Jin's
and these are like chewy ginger candies
and these are [ __ ] delicious like we
eat these really desert
yeah well it's a spicy apple flavor yeah
I don't like spicy don't eat it because
we gave one to Shannon it was too spicy
well that's part of ginger is it bites a
little bit if you're having it in its
pure form and if you're sensitive to
like kind of like spicy like like ginger
natural spice yeah ginger is gonna be a
little much for you but if you enjoy
that and you also want something that's
gonna like this curb your appetite like
as a dessert like you have it and you're
like oh like I'm spicy now I don't crave
anything yeah I understand you're coming
from I don't think you can claim that no
I'm just saying like it's your palette
yeah it's like if you like if you're
craving chocolate cake and you eat one
of those you're not gonna want to
awkward cake after I think that's
totally up to the person and how bad
they want chocolate cake but I
understand what you're saying okay it's
really good though I like them a lot
alright my next one is Oh an eg beanie
but I think that's also on my favorite
list is it yes well we have like 25 need
to be teased in this house they're
dispersed amongst many rooms and closets
but it is this is one of them is the
neat dewdrops go on but our friends
Chris Nick and John who owned the
company needed the beanies that they
make are the best beanies I've ever worn
so that's just a quick one bomb analysis
a beanie preferably black and meat dude
yeah well while we're on food I want to
go over my current favourite beer which
is the American pale ale made by gluten
burger this is a 360 view is the bottom
of it I have a limited selection of beer
I can have safely yeah drink cider of
beers see if it has a beer drinker I
enjoy beer so it's hard to find there's
a few there's a few companies that I
know make good beer
and this is one of my favorites it's not
my it's not my like all-time favorite
but it's my current favorite it's smooth
there's good flavor it's not an IPA so
it's not too intense but it isn't just
like a blonde so I don't know if you're
a beer drinker and you and it comes in
the tallboy size which I like this is my
this is my current favorite this is
absolutely delicious and for the
gluten-free options that I have this is
like right up there and it makes me feel
normal
it's really good though you're a drinker
and you cannot gluten I would recommend
it is a good beer alright my next one is
probably I'm pretty sure the most
expensive thing that's on here and it is
expensive try me [ __ ] like it's it when
we bought it I was like I don't know man
that seems like a [ __ ] lot but like
it's a Vitamix the blender oh if you I
feel like if you were just using your
blender for like smoothies like it's
totally unnecessary like that kind of
high powered blender at that price is
really because I used to use a blender
for years like ten plus years that was
nothing like a Vitamix and was totally
fine if you're just blending like fruit
and ice and stuff like that yeah but
once we got into the whole like we're
gonna make a cashew cream sauce or like
soup stuff or you know that getting more
creative with what we're cooking yeah
it's just the [ __ ] best thing in our
kitchen it's hard it's hard to imagine
having a normal blender after living
with the Vitamix yeah because like
you're eight like for instance like
here's an example if you want to make a
cashew cream sauce generally you have to
soak those cashews overnight so they're
soft enough to blend to do a cream not
with a Vitamix you just throw them in
with a Vitamix and they come for two to
four hours we just go just roll them in
there with the water and you're like oh
look at that it's so beautiful and ready
yeah the Vitamix is spectacular and if
you like again I know this sounds
annoying or whatever but if you're a
vegan and you're making a lot of like
cheese and cream substitutes by hand
which is a lot of time what you do and
it sounds tasking you know or taxing
rather when you when you hear that like
making sauce by hand but in reality
you're like you
just like a handful of ingredients in a
blender and it comes out as cheese cream
like and the the Vitamix is definitely
like the most capable thing I have my
kitchen it's really great for that stuff
I mean it's totally not a necessity and
I think that there are cheaper
high-powered blenders like on the market
but I'd say a high-powered blender that
we have experienced right yeah it's just
really much when do we buy that thing
like four years ago
even longer than that maybe five and
it's it's we use it everyday still
pretty much every single day yeah
because we usually make us at least one
smoothie a day at one point and then we
use it for dinner almost every single
night but well also maybe if you're a
vegan or a celiac or a person that
follows none of those things like you
could buy something and use it whereas a
lot of times we might be able to find
like a V pesto that has some sort of
gluten in it or something that's gluten
free and absolutely not vegan so we find
ourselves having obviously to like make
a lot of the stuff that we want so some
of that does come with you got a blend
up something and put it in something
yeah it's just I think we use it even
more than we're aware of you know we do
yeah we use it the more than a coffee
maker we used to use it more than the
company and say yeah that's nuts
yeah I think that I think you're
actually right I think that is the most
expensive thing on the list mm-hmm but
it's worth it
all right my next one this is something
I'm not sure if you can currently buy
but there is an artist by the name of
Alex Pardee who our friend Shannon
showed me who he was and he makes this
is his artwork right on the back of this
this is a pin print that he sold and I
think it was like a one-time thing and
it's sold out now but I bought two of
them I have one here and he did another
design I have in the other room and for
someone who loves pins collects pins and
makes pins you basically pin your your
favorite lapel pins on here and you hang
this up on the wall and then you have
the artwork with the pins decorated on
top of it's so cool and I have not seen
anything like this I've seen pin boards
I've seen coaching boards I've seen cork
boards but I've never seen anything
that's already filled with art and then
on top of it you put your pins I think
that's really cool so I have to pin
prints like I said this one hangs in
yeah so this one has all the pins that I
collect that are my favorite to display
because I have more and then the other
one oh yeah
so I think it's super cool he's actually
a really rad artist he's been doing like
twitch streams of his artwork it's
pretty cool like I love watching him
draw and stuff anyway I don't know if
you could buy it but it's Alex party's
parent even if someone couldn't buy it
that's something that you could make
it's such a cool idea to like make a
little canvas thing with a painting on
it yeah hey marble okay my next two go
together because I'm biased because
they're mine not really though but pop
sockets and a phone case with a wallet
in it can't I can't I don't know what I
did before this and I can never live
without it
the phone case with the wallet yeah
because I'm not the kind of girl that
really cares around a purse a lot used
to be and then he lost it oh yeah Oh sad
but even that was like a nice going out
purse that wasn't like a bluey no that's
like a wristlet yeah yeah I used to
carry a bracelet yes yeah but yeah my I
don't at this point I don't carry a bag
really every day and this is like I just
have all my credit cards and then you
know my water or whatever I'm bringing
with me but the specific brand of case
doesn't matter this is whatever you like
this one is by silk it says I think I
found Amazon yeah we did because then
you don't you know when you go into like
a store and they only have alt like a
certain kind of case and then they have
a bunch from those brands or whatever
and you're like oh I want all the cool
ones I see in Amazon how come you guys
don't carry different [ __ ] this is all
very corrupt but I really this is the
second one of this case that I have that
I keep my cards and license and stuff in
and then since I have a big-ass phone I
have to pop sockets which changed my
life and is the best thing in the world
because I can use my phone like this and
it sits as a little screen and then if I
pop it down a little bit now we can play
hearthstone law I mean breakfast and
[ __ ] I can hold it like this I put it in
between my fingers everyone's like
that's so unnecessary and I'm like yeah
well look at this it's amazing I love it
and we're still working on another round
of pop sockets so I'm
I apologize we're trying we might be
giving you some updates on that so we're
we're trying we're trying but I do I
genuinely cannot live without my double
pop sockets and my phone case with with
my cards in it all right
well on the topic of phone cases and pop
sockets I have the opposite I have
something called a love handle and I
trust me I like pop sockets I actually
have a few phone cases with pop sockets
on them so I'll swap them out from time
to time but something about this love
handle I love regardless the thing
that's more important that I want to
show you is this new phone case but it's
not just the case y'all this is a moment
phone case but it is part of the moment
mobile lens system this because you have
the case on those people you're attached
to people this is what it looks like
this is currently the 18 millimeter wide
lens so if you I don't want to be in a
red lens thank you very much you know
what I'm trying to show my car all right
so I don't know if you can see but like
check this out okay so that's that's the
shot you get normally and then you put
the lens on hold on I'm doing this
pretty gently okay and then you put the
lens on and I'm not much farther out you
see that so this is the wide lens and
I'm gonna show you the superfish which
is even wider
it's like distorted almost which is kind
of cool if you I do the macro lens as
well yeah where you can yes he got the
macro lens and some of these was so that
he could take it
cuz Julian Julian has lenses like that
for his camera and everything but you
didn't have a macro lens for your camera
no I'll take pictures of your opinion
yes exactly I don't a macro lens for my
like a full-blown lens to put on my AAA
7s is an expensive thing like $3,000 no
not like 3000 they're like upwards of
800 to like 2,000 depending or Lenzi yet
don't forget it used well and also like
I eventually be cool to have a macro
lens because the reason is when you get
a macro full like a full lens to put on
your mirrorless or DSLR you're not just
getting the in and the limiting thing
about the macro version of this is that
you can only photograph something right
on top of it if you move a little back
inside of focus with the proper camera
lens
it's the macro ability and focus goes
from
opposed to like here which this range is
the toughest to get with most lenses it
normally starts to get in focus out here
so instead of only being down here or
only being up here you fill that range
but for what I need which is taking up
close pictures of pins they sell a macro
so I bought the lens kit and it's it's
not cheap but the lenses are freaking
quality there's no distortion that you
can feel them in the way they attach
very easily there's a very specific type
of person that would buy that product in
your one yes and I would say the iPhone
ten if you have it it's like a great
freaking camera built into it so like
might as well get the most of it right
yeah
can I tell you a sad story what when I
was a kid I saw this really beautiful
picture like book I'm all these pictures
close-up of like plants and I was so
moved and excited by the photography in
this book and I was like oh my god I
want to take pictures like that so I
used the camera that I had which was a
ten dollar kodak disposable film camera
and i went out to my yard cuz you know
you just go to turn and you take a
picture and you don't see it it's gone
until you get your phone develop yeah
I'm going out to my backyard and I
started taking beautiful pictures of the
leaves and the flowers up really close
[ __ ] super close and I got that whole
roll of film back and I was like I just
do not understand how that man took
those pictures is it possible they were
so [ __ ] blurry
my mom was like that's great sweetie I'm
like mom look at them it's just all
green and blurry cuz I'm zoomed in on a
[ __ ] bush
it's cute though like when when a child
you know had just eyes have no idea like
what goes into it and I'm like I'm just
gonna go take pictures like [ __ ] that's
a sad story
yeah alright we moving on yeah but I
think we I just want to interject um
because I know you talked about your
leggings but I have something probably
even more comfortable with and leggings
and it's me at ease and I think honestly
you know we don't control we don't
exactly have our hand in of what week
what sponsor has fallen I think it's
perfect that me and he's felling this
week because they are actually my
favorite underwear
and they belong in the favourites
episode it's true
I wear me in these every single day I
don't want other underwear
I don't and until they invent pretty
close until they invent like a sport
compression short which I would I'm
desperately hoping for I will literally
only wear Mandi because the only time I
don't want to wear my jujitsu
compression trucks forever
me and these guys okay the softest
coolest underwear you could ever get I
have I don't even know this print is
called it's awesome they have literally
new prints each month there banana print
that they recently promoted a super cool
I can't wait to get mine in my mailbox I
don't have to go anywhere you give them
your size and they send you underwear in
the mail it seems like it's almost too
simple to like exist other companies not
figure that out it's so easy their
social sure that you will love their
underwear guys 100% satisfaction
guaranteed to you if you don't love your
first pair you get your money back ok
full refund right now the ding fam gets
20% off your first pair and they got the
shipping ok go to me undies calm that's
ME UND IES Stockholm / Jenna Julian pick
out a pair of underwear buy it with the
code and check it out put it on your bum
there's the thing why why are you here
no uh he's not wearing Mandy's anyway
guys check it out or click the link in
the bio they've absolutely changed my
life in the underwear arena and I never
want to go back so you can I never want
to go back I never want to go back to
the grocery store and pick out wine like
if sleep I want it to be shipped to me
by experts I want experts who know
exactly what they're talking about they
know wine they know what type of wine I
like they know my mouth very well
where's wink is an incredible service
imagine it's Friday you're tired you had
a long work week you don't want to think
the kids are being loud you're like hey
sit down and shut up
mommy needs a glass of wine
but well look dingdong knock knock open
the front door
it's a box you open it up Oh a shining
light comes out of it
it's Jesus but not really it's wink it's
your new wine that's been hand selected
by the wink team of delicious wonderful
wine that you didn't even have to exert
any mental effort on how to find that
line you pull it out of the box your
husband walks in hi hubby and you open
it you open it you pop the cork and then
you pour into a glass take your sips
all of a sudden your Friday is looking
up the kids have quieted down to reading
a book on their iPad and and life is
great all because a wink this this
scenario I know it sounds fake but it
could be you right now I want you get
out wink
go to try wink that's t ry winc calm /
annejulien guys you get $20 off your
first order and they're gonna cover the
shipping cost okay so you don't have to
worry about that check it out
awesome service that could be your life
moving on do you want me to drop you off
like a block away from school Sundays
yeah all right anyway so moving on
Gillian that was wonderful I love you
but like god dammit I hate you sometimes
you are just the worst
true love love hey hubby okay my next
thing is different gel dappling gel
point 1 acne treatment so when I was a
teenager like early high school so like
maybe ninth grade I feel like from 7th
to 8th grade to like ninth grade I had
like bacne not super bad but like to the
point where I was self-conscious and I
didn't want to wear like tank tops or
anything
and my mom took me to the doctor and
they had prescribed me different when I
was like which is currently still well
hold on so I used it and I cuz I was
really nervous
I had gone to like a school dance and I
wore like a feather boa to the best of
my ability to sort of cover up my back
and like obviously no one noticed it's
totally like a you thing and no one
cares but after that I was like mom I
was really you know like sad to go to
this dance because I'm like
self-conscious about my back entry cycle
thinking the doctor you know will get
somebody to get you something and I used
this and I swear on my life it like sort
of because I was washing it with like a
regular soap and then putting this on I
think dry two times a day to begin with
or one time and a day I think they've
just at night and it cleared up my skin
for like years like it didn't come back
through college and I had like had
stopped using it or like use it as like
a spa treatment and so yeah and then
like it just didn't come back and then
recently I was like no some of it sort
of is coming back because you know as
you're getting like older your hormones
change so your skin's like different
than it was when obviously when you're a
teenager or in college or whatever so I
was like I saw a commercial that was
like the FDA or whoever the [ __ ] just
approved different to be sold like in
OTC what's ot somebody current sorry
yeah looking a Rite Aid or CVS and I was
like that's really exciting because I
mean yeah maybe I would go to a
dermatologist and even though I don't
think I've ever done that in my life
really maybe once I did one time when
you were kid yeah and I was like that's
really [ __ ] dope so I just went to
like CVS and they have it and I was like
this is and now I can throw out all my
other ones that are just like the
salicylic acid or like benzoyl peroxide
cuz I feel like I always have very
mediocre results with that not really my
face I don't really have like acne on my
face but sometimes I'm like my back or
like where your bra strap goes and stuff
like that and it's just like it's the
best and I [ __ ] love it and you can
just get it at CVS so that's probably my
my jam huh that's dope yeah it's a cool
story actually
not being sarcastic a really cool story
they like it approved to be
over-the-counter and you found it as an
adult yeah like when you asked me to
help you out this is what I put well you
really can't put some different on it I
was like oh you just said well on the
topic of medicine
this isn't medicine these are drops I
like eye drops a lot I have naturally
really dry eyes so I pretty much daily
take eye drops and I've gone to eye
doctors and I've asked a lot of you know
doctors questions like what why am i red
late at night or what you know went
right in the morning why don't I feel
like I have to take odd jobs and I just
have been diagnosed with like really dry
eyes like that's what it is so I have
two separate ones that I like one is
approved by my doctor and one is
absolutely not this is the one that the
eye doctor recommends you can't see from
here it's called sustained ultra high
performance lubricant eyedrops this
basically helps me when I feel when I
when I wake up or I'm going to sleep
I've been staring at a screen a long
time I feel strained my eyes are dried
out this helps really like hydrate my
eyes this makes my eyes feel better but
that's it if my eyes are red and I put
these in they're gonna still be pretty
red after that's where these baby come
in layer this bad boy this guy he is
like he is like your your your closing
pitcher bottom of the 9th there's like
probably seven of those in and around
our couch and just these are he is my
Mario they're everywhere they're
everywhere in this house he comes in at
a late game and then you're always like
where my drugs I pop went in in my eyes
automatically and and this is the one
that my eye doctor was like don't take
that one don't do it why well it's just
these strain the blood vessels in your
eyes to the point where the blood
doesn't show anymore but it makes them
less red and it's literally only one
that I've used aside from like
prescription ones which I've had that
make my eyes not red so it's like these
and I don't have to use these every day
a lot of days I'll wake up in my house
we'll be fine they won't be red most
times I'll use this sometimes I'll use
this but just together I feel like I
have special eyes that have special
needs and I just people are [ __ ] rude
honestly two people wrong with your eyes
what are you [ __ ] high and it's
really annoying so I don't blame you
even though your doctor said don't use
that like it's really annoying yeah
having red eyes is not a fun thing
socially or on the internet yeah yeah
those two my bad boys right there
starting pitcher my bad okay
the next for the next four of mine are
all for the dogs so I'm going to go
relatively quickly okay so these are
actually the second sort of version of
this that I've bought the first the
first ones that I bought where I bought
them from Germany on a web site and
because they were sort of like a
prototype and if any of you guys have
been watch my boots are super a long
time you might have seen them but we
recently got rid of those just because
the these new ones became available that
we're like smaller and lighter and
easier and a little better to like
change the battery but I don't know if
these are waterproof the ones from
Germany were waterproof easily yeah so
we found these are like local pet store
and they come in like a super duper long
clear tube like this and this you know
when you buy it it's very long and then
you cut it to adjust for your pet size I
can't open mind let me do my favorites
I'm holding the Ambu display model so is
this one Hermes no that's marbles so
they light up and you press it one time
Hey okay sir you press it one time like
stop I'm putting it on the table I was
gonna show them and you make wearing it
I'm trying to help it out you press the
stop no I didn't touch your eye drop
absolutely did no roll it back
you press it one time to light up solid
and then you press so two times to blink
in my opinion I like I feel like this
should be law if you if you live in a
city or somewhere where there's like you
know if you live in the middle of
nowhere and you want to walk your dogs
and uncouth [ __ ] cares you know I'm
saying or even if you let them run out
in a field at night and you want to see
where they are but in my opinion in a
city these should be law because the
difference that they make is
just astounding it's like how you if I
law you need to wear a light when you're
riding your bike you know what I mean
like these do not substitute is your
dog's collar you slip them over their
head like this can you see criminal and
we've like we've messed around with the
leashes that also light up but to me as
long as they have a collar on that's
what really makes a difference because
then cars and other people walking can
see that you have animals and where they
are at night and it's just for safety
purposes this just makes a world of
difference and again like if you're the
kind of person that lives like on a farm
or like out in the middle of nowhere and
you let your dog sort of like run around
at night this is like amazing because
you can always see where they are at
night and you don't have to just like
rely on them coming when they're being
called and that kind of thing and I just
like I don't know how anybody functions
without this you know is when you walk
your dog at night you're in the dark or
in the rain or like that dusky hour
where it's really hard to see no matter
what like it's just so much safer and
I've had shown people stop me on the
street and be like where did you get
those what are those that's when they
were the old ones they didn't sell them
at stores or you know they sell the
little one that goes on the collar but
you can't see it from behind you know if
someone's driving from behind you they
can't see your dog's collar blinking in
the front you know the like a collar
option is just like the best thing in
the world and I really feel like it
should be a law maybe not a law but like
strongly advised you know I mean it
should be it should be more required
than it is like a little kid would you
let your little kid just like run around
in the street in the complete dark
you're like no dude that's not safe why
don't you play in the driveway until the
morning now is it it's really nice to be
able to see them at night especially
each by color geez pink and bubbles blue
and kuba is green also this is the
system of measuring their sizes is very
easily you just literally cut it to fit
the exact size and then you don't you
don't attach their leash or anything to
this like you they wear their collars as
normal and then they you do that again
so he can they can see without the mic
and yeah so like at night you just
you're slipping it on and off their head
and it's big
so you can slip it on an offer if they
have a funny shaped head you can attach
it together but like you're not going to
attach anything to this you know what I
mean it's just like a little necklace
that they wear but they get really
excited when you got a pink one this
one's we cheese why is it like that yes
baby thank you and then my next one for
the dogs is their car seat again
probably the second most expensive thing
on this list but I invested in it maybe
seven years ago like right around the
time I got permit or a little after and
I got it from a website called GW little
I'm sure you could find like the
manufacturer of it or like where they
maybe sell that but it straps into the
backseat of your car like a actual huge
like couch car seat for multiple dogs
and we strap them in there and it just
makes a world of difference because
they're up high so they're less anxious
it's safer for them they can all sit
there together they're not walking
around the car we're not doing this like
we put the car seat in the front or I
don't know it's just too much it's just
their backseat they're all in the
backseat if you have multiple little
dogs to me it was like a life-changing
experience to have that car seat yeah
and then also their dog stairs which I
also got from GW little they were not
cheap but that's because I went through
maybe three wooden stairs that I had
gotten from like a Petsmart or a Petco
and all my friends hot they were
hilarious little stairs and would step
on them and [ __ ] break them and it
used to drive me crazy in college it's
like everyone's drunk favorite thing to
do step on my little stairs and ruin
them it pissed me off they were from
Bubble how dare you but so I have
finally invested in those like soft ones
that are just shaped like scalloped
stairs all the difference in the world
and they've lasted at least seven years
out and greenies greenies is my last dog
favorite I don't know how we survived
without them there's it's like drugs to
them it is they don't get them like
every day but we give them at night sort
of like not dinner but like bedtime sort
of and it's just their favorite thing in
the world they just love greenies their
actual crack for dogs so collars dog bed
greenies
and better friends and stairs mm-hmm
friends that won't crush your dog stairs
yeah okay my next item is fanny packs in
general but most recently this one this
is a an REI small pack well it's
relatively compact which I like because
I have a couple big fanny packs which
you know they're good but if you need
something low-profile that you need
quick access low profile
oh hi intense low low profile oh you
have two separate pockets but what's
cool about these pockets and I have a
bunch of my favorites inside of them I'm
going to take them out inside you have
it almost looks like it was kind of
built for cameras because there's like
these two like pockets and you put I put
batteries in there for my cameras and I
can haul batteries very easily and
cereal and I could I can pour cereal and
you do that my penny pack and then this
outside pocket is even smaller I put my
SD cards in there see there's one in
there right now it's real pretty nice
and if I'm ever feeling a little Oh
crazy sometimes a word over my shoulder
but I normally do that with the bigger
fanny packs since that was really short
one I'm gonna do my flashlights next
these these are these are the MVPs now
these are not all of them these are just
my favorites I have a Dinant headlamp
would you consider yourself a flashlight
connoisseurs I don't like you are no no
I'm very in trouble but I am subscribed
to the flashlight subreddit so I learn
every day this is a headlamp I think a
headlamp is something that everyone
should have period it is incredibly
helpful for times when you need to do
something at night that you weren't
planning on doing checking the breaker
at the back your house going check
checking things I use that to walk the
dogs sometimes it's incredibly helpful
when you want to be hands-free and you
want light a headlamp they're super
cheap mm-hmm
you can get them on Amazon this is a
little higher end when I got this one at
REI they have some really nice ones that
you're gonna and I'm telling you
flashlights they're fun man so like if
you get into it you're gonna want to get
good ones so this is mine it has a
couple different settings and then these
are my two babies right here these are
Phoenix flashlights this is the PD 35
tactical this is my main boy right here
it's a
big one I'm not joking when I tell you
Julian doesn't leave the house without a
flashlight uses 18 650 battery takes
them everywhere which are big boy
batteries these are not doublea's these
are 18 650 so they require an entirely
separate charging system don't know last
time I chart this battery was it can go
up to with its with its strobe mode a
thousand lumens which is enough to in
like for temporary measures blind
someone not that I wanna do that but
there we go so I'm gonna flash you guys
real quick
BAM really really bright this one is
this one is like my the one I take when
we go on trips or we're camping or we're
going somewhere and this is my like
grab-and-go mini version this one
something like that out to dinner and it
might get dark
it's he carries it with him everywhere
he's trying to track down your lift
that's literally what it is it's
incredibly helpful guys a good
flashlight is worth all theirs peace of
mind having a good flashlight and you
know what now I don't go anywhere
without mine so it also means that I
don't need a good flashlight and I don't
need to carry one you hear that ladies
and men okay your flashlights in here
ladies and men won't need one
oh I only got a couple more okay I think
I'm gonna cut a half yeah well cut some
out to this though this I feel like is
like a life hack okay so we went through
so many like throw blankets for the
couch and they were all like I was
unhappy with how big they were I wanted
them to be bigger and so we did this
stupid thing where we go to like Target
or whatever and we're looking at the
blankets it's so good so it's big enough
for two people Luba and then finally I
like sis knocked I had done had it with
throw blankets and their fancy [ __ ]
and I just don't like it don't like it
not here for I just want a big
comfortable [ __ ] blanket so you girl
head bit over headed over sorry yes he
he did I headed over to the bedding
section and I said you know those little
blankets that they sell for your bed in
a queen-size I forget are these queen or
king size they're king these are huge by
the king size just get a blanket
for a bid not one that's meant as a
throw throw blanket use it as a might
use it as your blanket so these are like
legit they're the size of a bed but
they're thin enough material to not like
you know it's not like having a
comforter downstairs but even the ones
that we put on top of the couch like
those are queen-size blankets meant for
a bed but they're the best blanket for
man and they're large which is one thing
I appreciate yeah and now I'm done
shopping for throw blankets because we
finally have some that we really like
that will fit and then not get ruined
because they're little mm-hmm me I got
so sick of [ __ ] little ass blankets
they do love them
yeah but yeah give yourself a queen or
king size blanket meant for a bed and
use that as your throw mm-hmm if you
down for blanket time if you're not down
for a blanket time what are you doing no
I don't know all right my next item is
something I use for my camera I think
I've showed this before I've definitely
show this before and I think you guys
might know what this is this is made by
peak design okay and it is a camera belt
clip so basically you will get stopped
at the airport yeah tsa doesn't like
this but you you put your belt on and
then when your belts on you thread this
through and then you loosen the knobs
and you your belt goes in between there
so you're basically like clamping this
onto your belt and then what you do is
you clip your camera in and it locks in
with this little mechanism right here
you can you hear out on my camera with
me but you can hear it it clicks in like
it clicks in like that and there's even
a lock function where if you don't this
is the button that releases it but if
you want it so the button won't release
it you turn it once and then it's locked
so that you're afraid of someone hitting
it in the camera going fine just keep
this on it's an eye lit anywhere I'm
carrying my camera I have this on my
belt and it makes filming not only vlogs
but like bigger projects LMT or whatever
I'm shooting where I have multiple
things going on I can't just hold one
camera and be occupied with that I need
to be able to like pop it on my hip and
do something else
hugely hugely huh he does every single
time get stopped at TSA and they make
him take it off and look at it and stuff
yeah well lately I just been
just been putting in my bag yes but yeah
I don't think about they don't they
don't like that they don't like that
but yeah that's about camera clip and it
works with the attachment plate that
goes on right on my tripod so what my
camera it'll pop on this I take it off
and with the same mounting plate it goes
on my tripod you love that thing it's
pretty great you use that like every day
my next ones are all beauty related I'll
do them together these is my favorite
beautiful people things this I think is
like usually around ten dollars so this
one was eleven dollars again I think
that beauty supplies are charges a
little more than usual this is now my
second or third one of these this wet
detangle professional what's the name of
the company is wet wet wet brush gross
wet I would have named it moist gross
this is the best my favorite hairbrush
that I've ever used I love it my
hairdresser years ago was like oh do you
have a wet brush and I was like what the
[ __ ] is that she was like here and it
looks like any other hair brush like the
cons used when I was a kid they sell
them in like black and all different
colors I was like I don't get why it's
great it really it just sits you can use
it on your wet hair you use on your dry
hair and I literally use the other one
like to the bone because I'll style it
with heat products and that probably
damaged it a little bit after four years
of use it's pretty nice so I finally
just got a couple new ones and they're
just my favorite [ __ ] brush he's got
a wet brush hmm and then benefit they're
real mascara is my all-time favorite
mascara I think I've ever tried
I just recently tried they have a new
one bad gal bang or whatever I still
like this better and my favorite thing
in the world is to wear the black on my
lashes are like with fake lashes and
then they sell a primer or like a brown
mascara on the bottom lashes because it
still looks like just as dark like in a
picture or on camera or something like
that but it looks really natural in
person and not as like black that's
tight because I have like really pale
[ __ ] white people's skin and black
mascara sometimes just looks real scary
on my bottom lashes you know just real
scary
I got my favorite lashes ever
now listen okay like I've dabbled in
some fancy girl lashes like the crazy
expensive ones that are like $26 for
like one set and they're like well you
can wear it six times I'm like yeah I
understand but like I got drunk and one
of them fell off and I don't know where
it is anymore
okay but like I'm all for like maybe a
fancier pair of lashes if you're a girl
that wears lashes or a guy that wears
lashes a lot but these are like my go-to
all the time if I just want to throw on
a pair of lashes these are my [ __ ]
there are del demi whispies because I
feel like you can dress them up enough
to be like nice if you want it to look
nice for a night out but you didn't want
to wear a big heavy lash and they're
always good and small enough to be like
nice during the day I mean depending on
your eye size or shape maybe you're
looking for something really tiny but
for me it's a good size to wear and I'm
like I'm wearing lashes but they're not
super invasive they look a little more
than natural but not too much and
they're not that expensive isn't very
versatile
yeah that's my [ __ ]
and now they sell them in bigger packs
which I'm happy about because they go
through them kind of best mm-hmm and
then you make fun of me for where I
leave my lashes he's left one on my
computer the other day like on my
physical laptop I'm really sorry
that's good probably an accident it's
all good
I can probably end my favorites there I
think I can have my favorite say I was
gonna include tiny hand but he's an
obvious loves this tiny hand well yeah
this was this was cool I hope you guys
enjoyed the favorites obviously we can
do this again we have more things that
we can show you if you want us to focus
on any specific sort of favorites or
whatever let us know but yeah let us
know in the comments what some of these
maybe you already use for some of your
favorites because I'm keen to know what
you guys use yeah I agree
or if you have any flashlight
suggestions for Julian
let's have a flashlight party I love
flashlights you guys have a wonderful
week
this Wednesday Jenna and I are actually
gonna be playing in a pub G tournament
live on Twitch
it's gonna be real fun how I got here
where there's giving more information
soon so stay tuned on our twitter at
Jenna Julianne if you want that but we
got we'll be playing this Wednesday so
check it out thank you guys for hanging
out we'll see you next to go next
episode
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]